Guten morgen tim.
Null eins eins acht neun neun neun acht acht eins neun neun neun neun eins eins neun sieben zwei fünf drei.
Track 3
Logbuch netz politik nummer dreihundert und dreizehn vom siebenundzwanzigsten september zweitausendneunzehn diesen freitag und da sitzen wir hier früh morgens wie wir 's gewohnt sind.
Und ich habe die nummer nicht parat aber das war ja das war ja eigentlich relativ einfach zu merken null eins eins acht neun neun neun acht acht eins neun neun neun eins eins neun sieben zwei fünf.
Es war ein bisschen falsch.
Die habe ich mir falsch gemerkt oh gott was mache ich denn da.
Ja relativ einfach null eins eins acht neun neun neun acht acht eins neun neun eins eins neun sieben zwei fünf drei.
An einer rhythmik muss man nochmal arbeiten wie auch immer wir haben jetzt durch gestellt und wo komm ich dann raus.
Bei der notfall nummer da musste man muss natürlich auch sofort wissen was du dann sagst erste erste frage ist wer meldet welches system ist betroffen.
Mein telefon.
Welche wie haben sie mit dem it-system gearbeitet.
Ich hab versucht es einzuschalten.
Was haben sie beobachtet.
Es hat sich nicht einschalten.
Wann ist das ereignis eingetreten.
Wo befindet sich das betroffene it-system gebäude gebäude raum arbeiten.
Na hier auf meinem tisch in der mieter ebene.
Ja okay dann haben wir das jetzt an bei den notfall aufgenommen jetzt ist wichtig ja genau jetzt ist wichtig sie müssen.
Was soll ich denn jetzt machen welches verhalten solcher tag legen.
Genau die weitere arbeit am it-system bitte einstellen deine beobachtungen dokumentieren.
Ja ich mache gleich ein podcast dazu.
Und die maßnahmen nach anweisung einleiten nur nur nach anweisung einleiten und natürlich sowieso ruhe bewahren.
Nur nach anweisung ja okay lieber einmal mehr als einmal zu wenig anrufen.
Das hat das man fragt sich immer was macht der ne.
Was macht eigentlich.
Was macht das ja.
Die waren beim tuning i notfall zettel.
Also ich muss jetzt darauf aufmerksam gemacht hat mich gestern andré lampe der ja auch wahrscheinlich als podcast da fehlen bekannt ist und ich hab das dann als der tim kurz weg war ausgedruckt und hier in der meter ebene aufgehängt.
Und ich halte das für ein witz.
Das erste mal nicht ernst genommen hätte.
Linus hatte wieder zu viel zeit sagte weil so über beschäftigt aber setzt er sich wieder und malz und i notfall zettel oder das also das war so authentisch lustig
mir dachte so ja ja auf so sowas läuft irgendwann vielleicht dann doch nochmal hinaus.
Es gab es kam dann noch natürlich sofort eine korrektur weil dann natürlich der kann ja also die notfall nummer die selber eintragen.
Haben wir gemacht.
Die kennen wir ja auch.
Und dann kann man auch direkt von ich würde sagen das spricht man aus black coffee also null coffee,
coffee falls da fehlen natürlich ein paar infos die man da noch mit drauf schreiben muss halt es korrigiert ding ausgefüllt wo eben erstmal die notfall rufnummer drauf steht dann,
der name des ersten haustiere.
Mädchen damit der mutter.
Geburtsort mädchenname der mutter lieblingsfarbe und passwort.
Dass dass man die sachen sich auch noch direkt mit dazu schreibt sehr schön.
Das mit diesen sicherheitsfragen das stimmt aber jetzt auch langsam aus oder.
Äh zum glück also zum glück das war ja wirklich eine der dümmsten idee,
die jeweils jemand hatte mit diesen
öffentlich verfügbaren sicherheitsfragen,
das ja da kann man wirklich sagen da stirbt glaube ich zum glück langsam aus.
Kleiner tipp wenn ihr noch so ein system habt behandelt einfach jeder dieser fragen wie ein passwort fällt und generiert euch da einfach ein passwort und speichert die einfach nochmal ab als passwort eins zwei drei und dann habt ihr da die richtigen fragen die keiner beantworten kann für euch.
Genau nicht einfach ein anderes tier angeben wie ich schon mal sagte,
so der lieblingstiere wurden relativ wenig tiere so das ist ein relativ kleiner zu.
Lumpen.
Form bad ist da drin maus katze hund.
Also das tier ist in.
Lieblingsserie soll's ja dein lieblingszitat.
Ach so ja.
So da gibt's jetzt irgendwie wie viele gibt's hund katze ratte meerschweinchen.
Vogel fährt fährt mit tee oder ne da gibt's nur je nachdem wie früh man das pferd bekommen hat.
Ich dachte man muss den namen seines lieblingstier das angeben das haustier ist sowas kommt doch auch wie ist dein erstes haustier ja die heißt ja auch alle gleich.
Ja der ist noch nicht mütter eis noch alle gleich.
Ja vor allem mit mädchen nahmen.
Total nehmen nicht machen machen wir nicht sowas machen wir nicht da schreiben wir schön in jedes feld einfach etwas ein sehr langen zufälligen string und dann war das gewesen.
Ja es ist auch für so so öffentliche und halb öffentliche personen finde ich auch immer wieder erstaunlich irgendwelchen telefon support hotlines sind die einem dann noch irgendwas retten wollen dann fragen sie einen immer so sachen,
sollte ich die wirklich mal über mich vergessen haben dann kann ich dir auch in der wikipedia nachschlagen.
Ich war natürlich.
So und freue mich auch so wegwischen grad von absicherung verspricht ihr euch jetzt eigentlich durch diese prozedur.
Das hätte ich jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht erwähnen sollen weil gleich morgen
zeigt mir meine sim-karte woanders hin aber das sind halt auch prozedur über die unternehmen mal nachdenken muss immer hast du mit sowas nicht auch regelmäßig zu tun dass das also solche recovery prozesse mal ordentlich mal.
Regelmäßig kaputt ne also das ist ja üblicher also damit hast du natürlich auch regelmäßig hier zu tun in diesem bereich,
haben wir da noch zuletzt drüber gesprochen anfang des jahres ne diese ganzen boxing dinger wo dann äh vor ein paar jahren gab 's doch auch diese wirklich traumhafte kombination,
wie kann ich mich daran erinnern das war also es waren so in london sex weil der eine anbieter hat zur verify kaution.
Letzten kreditkartennummer hinten und die anderen vorne.
Vorne,
und man muss halt die letzten eingeben oder so ne das also ganz das ist alles sehr sehr schlecht solche solche sachen als recovery zu nehmen und das darf das nicht machen erinnert mich an diese ps die,
zwei geschichte letztes letztes mal wo eben der das recovery am ende dann doch über sms ging hauptsache man hat keine semestern,
womit wir auch beim feedback werden.
Aber ich kann jetzt ich kann jetzt tote bär hat gerade gesagt ich kann jetzt mit meinem iphone kann ich jetzt auch meinen personalausweis schön mit c auslesen und super online.
Aus whatsapp ich habe gestern versucht die runterzuladen da war sie noch nicht da gibt's jetzt.
Geil ausweis äpfeln fürs i phone darauf habe ich gewartet tatsächlich weil damit unter umständen.
Mehr möglichkeiten mit dem sc ausweis app zwei zack ins tor nehme ich.
Wie wer also immer gleich mal hier gleich wieder rum zu moser an wer bitte denkt sich so ein scheiß aus ihr macht da so eine offizielle app zum auslesen des personal.
Und wieso heißt das ding ausweiß app zwei.
Die erste.
Warum zwei warum app warum überhaupt warum warum beschreibt ihr nicht einfach das was es tut ja.
Das schön viel schöner ist tatsächlich wenn du,
wenn du als ich das gestern noch im app store gesucht habe dann die anderen empfehlungen die du dafür kriegst ist camp scanner mobile scanner export dann,
passport foto ist irgendwie eine app die darauf achtet dass das bild bio methodisch ist ausweis irgendwie weiß ich auch nicht genau da gibt's ein ausweis sie weiß dann,
doch.
Genau doch der wurde empfohlen wird deine ausweispapiere zu scannen ja alles spannend ich bin mal gespannt also diese app werde ich dann mal ausprobieren da reden wir nächste woche drüber.
Aber das jetzt deutschland in der benennung von software keine vorreiter schafft hat ist auch klar länger weil wir über dieses i notfall dingen so gelacht haben,
das ding ist wahrscheinlich dass das in einigen unternehmen nicht unbedingt,
eine schlechte sache wäre um sie aufzuhängen ich war das ding was unternehmen sein.
Wenn eine telefonnummer eingetragen wird.
Wenn eine telefonnummer eingetragen ist ja ich,
seht ihr schon bei einigen,
die denn deine e-mail-adresse eingetragen haben oder so aber natürlich es ist einfach eine etwas was gerade unternehmen probleme macht sind hauptsächlich sachen und da ist natürlich zu melden so ich habe hier,
ein notfall gespannt wie viele anrufe da dann eigentlich also
es ist traurig es ist furchtbar aber wahrscheinlich ist das noch nicht mal so blöd in einem unternehmen so etwas auf,
hängen zu haben bevor die leute dann irgendwie falsche dinge machen oder so.
Ja und auch noch einen zettel für alle anderen sachen die einen so im unternehmen auch üblicherweise passieren kann und freundliche kollegen und wie böse chefs einfach auch eine entsprechende notfall nummer.
Ja meter ebene notfall rufnummer podcast war zu langweilig.
Haben wir doch wenn wir haben eine.
Schnell genug runter.
Du du magst das ja nicht so aber wir haben ja die.
Jetzt nicht wieder das feedback.
Gut also feedback etwas mehr feedback dies war christian frage an linus wieso sollte eine app installiert auf einem smartphone sicherer sein als der zukunft per webbrowser auf einem gepatcht pc,
inklusive der nächsten frage wie mache ich denn den zweiten faktor auf dem smartphone habe ich dann ein zweites smartphone dabei,
ich glaube da ist ein interessanter ein interessantes missverständnis aufgetaucht denn,
nur weil etwas app heißt heißt es nicht dass auf einem smartphone installiert ist ab steht für applikation und dies nicht notwendigerweise mobile und selbstverständlich benutze ich keine mobile apps.
Wobei app auch nicht heißt dass ich nicht dann doch wieder um eine web anwendung handelt so.
Da kommt als nächstes zu aber ja ne ich habe tatsächlich ich habe irgendwie auf meinem handy so eine finanzen app installiert die hab ich aber nie fertig,
gefüllt mit daten aber trotzdem vergleichst du hier
äpfel mit birnen die frage stellt konkreter manfred da wird deine frage nämlich dann auch beantwortet verstehe linus aussage bezüglich online-banking via webbrowser und auch nicht ganz gibt es außer ist macht man nicht,
noch andere gründe gründe die dagegen sprechen ja denn primär die angriffsfläche deines webbrowser.
Hat irgendwelche plugin der hat script sprachen wie javascript und bei einer applikation
ja habe ich zumindest nicht die sorge dass wenn mir jemand geld überweist mit verwendungszweck eines javascript dass mein verrückter browser die dann irgendwie ausführt abgesehen davon ist,
das kernproblem bei den meisten irgendwie angriffen im web die mit geld zu tun haben fishing,
und genau dieses problem hast du nicht mehr wenn du mit einer banking-app arbeitest,
ja das irgendwie läuft dass dir eine andere oberfläche vorgetäuscht wird dass du auf einer anderen seite bist dass du ihr wenn das nicht deine normalen arbeitsverhältnisse sind
dich in irgendwelchen komischen aufs kuren webseiten einzug loggen dann verringert du dieses problem auch aus sicherheitsaspekt live.
Der grund ist einfach schlicht das web bringt halt sein user interface immer immer noch mit,
und die app hat es halt auf dem gerät außerdem sind natürlich ist das web einfach auch quasi nochmal so ein us zusätzlich obendrauf und das macht die sache einfach nicht.
Ich würde gerne noch kurz was ausführt zu diesem fishing sachen.
Ein beliebtes beispiel oder eine beliebte cover story für fischen angriffe ist zum beispiel zu sagen,
du musst dein passwort ändern ja klicke hier um dein passwort zu ändern und ich mach ja welchen bereich,
die sicherheit ich finde durchaus öfter mal solche probe angriffe in dem bereich und so und das was,
stärksten in unternehmen die wahrscheinlichkeit senkt dass die leute auf solche fishing angriffe reinfallen ist tatsächlich wenn die passwort,
erneuerung routine sich nicht über eine website abdeckt weil die leute nicht trainiert werden,
in webseiten solche sachen einzu tippen ja es ist eine ganz einfache frage von.
Welche gewohnheiten haben die menschen im umgang mit dieser,
mit dieser kritischen aufgabe trainiert man den an die ganze zeit passwörter in web oberflächen einzu tippen oder trainiert man das denn ab,
und das ist ganz,
klarer grund lieber solche banking apps zu nutzen damit man sich nicht daran gewöhnt irgendwie finanzielle finanziell relevante daten irgendwelche browser einzutreten außerdem,
hast du eine stabile oberfläche über verschiedene konten und auch so sachen wie backups weißt du ich mein wenn du,
guck dir mal an wie lange die diese web oberfläche noch deine kontoauszüge bereitstellt oder deine
deine daten die da irgendwie drin sind das ist also irgendwie alles äußerst windiges wetter,
wenn das irgendwie in einem browser betrieben wird die app hat eine sehr viel geringere anderes oberfläche
ja und gleichzeitig ist das
in homogene ja also die fishing angriffe auf sparkasse bin ich immun gegen wenn ich sobald ich eine andere oberfläche benutze irgendwelche diese ganzen oberflächen angriffs oberflächen browser skript sprache so haben diese apps alle nicht und es gibt unterschiedliche apps,
das heißt aus meiner tätig aus meiner bank kann ich auf die app geschlossen werden während in umgekehrten fällen das natürlich schon getan werden kann,
die oberfläche.
Da wird doch was anfügen.
Ja selbstverständlich.
Und ich glaube das hat man aber auch erwähnt,
app heißt dann auch in der regel wenn es sich halt nicht um so eine bekloppte app handelt die letzten endes auch nichts anderes als im webbrowser in das geist ist das hat man ja oft ne dass das so 'ne so 'ne macht einen auf und dann dann dann dann kriegst du letztlich auch nur eine webseite.
Von deiner bank ja.
Sowas gibt's nicht nur von der bank sonst gibt's bei allem möglichen,
aber in der ideale welt und insbesondere in diesem kontext von konto abfrage und der nutzung von hc
ist halt einfach sinnvoller eine abstraktion zwischen benutzeroberfläche und der bank zu haben weil dann wird halt ein protokoll gesprochen was
im prinzip nichts anderes tun tut als das was es also so sollte es sein ja es ist quasi auf diesen fall reduziert,
das kann natürlich immer noch sicherheitslücken haben aber du trends einfach die dinge von daher besser und dritte eben nicht noch dieses ganze in parlament noch zusätzlich mit rein das ist dann im zweifelsfall auch schneller,
und zahlreiche andere vorteile also ich bin ein großer freund dieser app logik und.
Aus dem gleichen grund liest man übrigens keine e-mails im browser.
Ja
Weil du eben mit deinem mail klein sagen kannst wir machen hier mal kein javascript wir machen jemand kein l wir wollen hier text durch die gegend schicken,
und wir gehen einfach mal mit dem flammende schwert,
durch den durch den teil mit dem diese e-mail überhaupt noch interagiert wie viel komplexer,
in ihrer darstellung,
anwendung findet und irgendwie,
webbrowser sind inzwischen so komplex wie betriebssysteme vor zehn jahren waren ja
das also da gab es insgesamt allgemeine kommentare irgendwie zu technischen sicherheits-
top oder sonst was die gehen tatsächlich am thema vorbei denn über technische schwachstellen wirst du,
sehr viel seltener in deinem online-banking bereich angegriffen als über menschliche ja es gibt natürlich dann schadsoftware zum
extrahieren des zweiten faktoren auch schon seit jahren irgendwie eine sigma ist da irgendwie glaube ich der klassiker sus in dem mobile wo es dann irgendwann,
anfing dass der zweite faktor per sms auf die telefone kam haben sie dann schadsoftware für die telefone gebaut und so aber letztendlich,
so die die größere teil der leute verliert seine kohle durch menschliche fehler im umgang mit irgendwelchen oberflächen
und diesen dieses problem kann man dem problem kann man versuchen zu entgehen.
Dann kommt noch ein kommentar von frau christine die sagt ich habe kein smartphone,
und spiel bei meinem einen konnten und jetzt vor dem problem dass dass sie,
nicht in der lage ist ein zweiter faktor zu generieren weil das alles nur noch mit irgendwelchen apps funktioniert,
sie versucht jetzt hat sich überlegt sie könnte vielleicht irgendwie ein smartphone simulator,
ihren computer benutzen um darauf dann irgendwie diese tanne app auszuführen wenn die tanne irgendwie halbwegs ordentlich gebaut ist dann wird die sich genau weigern,
auf auf auf einem imola tor zu zu laufen da sind also das ist der haupt,
sicherheitsarchitektur dieser apps ist sich gegen gerettete umgebung und sonstiges zu zu wehren ich bin auf jeden fall sehr gespannt.
Trolli schnittlauch empfahl ihr dann ja du wirst halt ein hardware generator brauchen sowieso ein wo du halt eine.
Gerät chipkarte.
Chip tan lesegerät oder sowas ne.
Das nervt natürlich auch weil das hat man im zweifelsfall immer nicht dabei.
Es ist nicht dabei aber gut dabei ist jetzt eine sache nur das problem ist sie hat ist ein vereinssport dafür gibt es keine also das wird spannend da bin ich auf jeden fall sehr gespannt liebe frau christine ob du das geld nochmal wieder siehst und,
und bin dann sehr sehr sehr interessant.
Aber aber leute ruft eure banken an ruft mit solchen problemen ruft
support an erzählt denen dass das alles nicht geht es einfach das gerade jetzt noch wo diese ganze psd zwei umstellung so neu ist die sollen schwitzen sie sollen einfach merken was sie da angerichtet.
Was übrigens wurde dann auch noch kommentiert wir hätten unsere kritik richtete sich gegen die psd zwei,
das tut sie nicht unsere kritik
richtet sich primär dagegen dass jede bank die psd zwei jetzt anders interpret interpretiert hat und versucht hat irgendetwas anders umzusetzen es wäre durchaus begrüßenswert wenn die jetzt beispielsweise eine
einheitlichen standard für second factor apps hatten von mir aus könnte diese eine app in der ich dann alle meine banken tanz,
sammle nach einem standardisierten verfahren auch noch einmal passwort geschützt sein ist alles in ordnung aber ich kann nicht zum abruf von vier oder fünf konnten mit vier oder fünf unterschiedlichen apps
interagieren die auf ganz unterschiedlichen wegen und voraussetzungen irgendwie diese verfluchten tanz zur verfügung stellen.
Und vor allem da müssen wir noch nicht mal was neu erfinden das gibt es seit jahren heißt op ja.
Müsste also tatsächlich müsstest du das ein bisschen erweitern weil die psd zwei schreibt vor das titan dynamisch generiert ist und für diesen,
vorgang und passwort ist einfach nur immer ein passwort also aber daran angelehnt,
könnte man sehr schöne intelligente option machen die wenigstens einfach vereinheitlicht sind,
und jetzt wie gesagt mit tausend apps zu jonglieren bitte gar nicht geht gar nicht und da muss ich da muss sich was ändern,
gefragte noch tobias ihr sagt er setzt er sei entsetzt dass die leute webseiten nutzen ja sind wir und,
dass man mehrere konnten haben sollte während erstes irgendwo logisch ist frage ich mich worin die begründung für mehrere konnten liegt interessante vermutung sicherheit wenn eine bank gehackt wird nein also,
ganz ehrlich wenn eine bänke bank gehackt wird kriegt ihr euer geld zurück ja es gibt ganz wenige fälle das haben wir hier auch glaube ich damals behandelt es gibt eigentlich nur ein sicherheits- fahren,
bei dem ihr die schuld tragt wenn eine transaktion ausgelöst wird und das ist diese chip tannen verfahren weil ihr da eben spezifisch die transaktion,
freigebt wenn ihr das tut und damit im prinzip eine,
ausgeschlossen ist dass irgendwelche männer die mittel verschiedene mittel angriffe funktionieren.
Weil ihr am ende auf diesem tann generator noch einmal spezifisch steht,
und der ist ja eine getrennte hardware wo dann eben drauf steht hier du überweist jetzt zehntausend euro auf die seychellen wenn du diesen code eingibst und damit da gibt es eben ein urteil wo eine.
Ich glaube das war damals eine anwaltskanzlei,
um geld erleichtert wurde und gesagt wurde dieses sicherheits verfahren kann nur bei menschlichen,
ausgehebelt werden und aus diesem grunde ist die bank hier nicht haften und was ja auch zu dem,
punkt geführt hat dass ich immer dazu rate das unsichersten tanz verfahren zu wählen um im zweifelsfall vor gericht
mit der unsicherheit des verfahrens argumentieren zu können was eben bei sichereren tanz verfahren nicht mehr so einfach der fall ist und das wird mit der psd zwei sich jetzt eben auch verschiedene werden wir auch neue rechtsprechung im zweifelsfall bekommen aber,
bei der verwendung mehrere konnten geht es nicht darum dass ich jetzt das geld verteile auf verschiedene banken in der hoffnung dass nur,
dass äh einige davon nur gehackt werden das spielt erst ab betrieben von einhunderttausend euro eine rolle im rahmen der einlagen sicherung das habt ihr sicherlich alles gelesen als euer konto eröffnet habt dass ihr pro bank,
nur für hunderttausend euro sicherheit und garantie habt die restlichen fünf sechshunderttausend euro die sind halt dann irgendwie im risiko.
Wasser muss ich ja nochmal zehn kunden aufmachen.
Schwierig schwierig schwierig ne deswegen aktien kaufen tim da kriegt das geld auch so schnell weg.
Manche haben sie auch gewundert warum,
warum man überhaupt mehrere kunden hat hab da jetzt auch mit wochenende frischer schonmal stellen zugenommen vielleicht kurz nochmal zusammengefasst.
Betrifft natürlich nicht alle leute aber es gibt in,
bei den leuten die selbstständig sind natürlich erhöhte,
viele gründe erstmal,
willst du privat von beschäftigten trennen dann musst du auch geschäftlich unter umständen mehrere dinge trennen dann.
Kann vielleicht halt auch die eine bank das eine besser als das andere ja auch sowas wie ein paypal-konto ist ein konto und
muss man einfach nochmal mit dazu zählen grad im ganzen online wesen gibt's ja nochmal so diverse mittels männer die halt manchmal einfach die bessere lösung
wir sind für eine bestimmte anwendung also das wird eher der normalfall sein.
Also allein als privatperson würde ich immer mindestens zu zwei konten raten tagesgeldkonto
girokonto weil du natürlich mit hilfe des kontos mit einem durchschnitten was weiß ich,
geld eingang der dann in der regel monatlich ist wenn wir jetzt von der nicht selbstständigen person reden da hast du natürlich irgendwie dein
budget des monats ganz gut im blick kannst den rest abführen auf dem tagesgeldkonto und hast eine saubere trennung zwischen was hab ich an ersparte und wie sieht dieser monat geradeaus ne muss ich den
enger schnallen oder so ne also einfach auch um eine übersicht zu halten bisher mehrere konnten haben nicht irgendwie dein gesamtes vermögen,
auf einem konto haben von dem was du dann irgendwie agierst.
Auch bei selbstständigen thema mit um die umsatzsteuer zurücklegen und so weiter es gibt einfach viele gründe und das ist auch einfach die regeln.
Dann wollen wir mal noch jobs job empfehlungen.
Ja mach mal da gibt's wieder einiges in unserem umfeld wo man sich bewerben kann unter anderem bei der.
Tschüss.
Dann auf ihr business,
die von max schrimps,
es sicher zum ziel gesetzt hat seit letztes jahr am fünfundzwanzigsten mai die,
datenschutzrichtlinie in kraft getreten ist dass es nun.
Datenschutzgrundverordnung genau den artikel achtzig gibt der eben.
Aktion also quasi rechtliche klagen aus der zivilgesellschaft vorsieht,
um strafen herbeizuführen und das baut ja,
neu auf quasi als die das strategisch,
tut um damit der den datenschutz zu erreichen der von der data protecting regulation.
Geplant ist ne also strategisches vorgehen im datenschutz bereich auf juristischer aber natürlich auch technischer weise und deswegen suchen sie einmal softwareentwickler rennen,
für ligaalltag durchaus kein ohne interessanter bereich auch wenn ihr euch dann irgendwann mal aus dem bereich weg orientieren wollt seid ihr wahrscheinlich mit legal in einem interessanten,
feld wo es wenig expertise gibt und wahrscheinlich breite märkte.
Und sie suchen mit level und ziemiak ähm also juristin,
so mit level ist dann ab drei jahren ist ab sechs jahren erfahrung,
und da haben wir links zu den job ausschreibungen,
in den shorts und weil wir dann grade schon in österreich war ich schon mal im österreichischen internet unterwegs war,
direkt noch geguckt ob center gerade leute sucht epic inter sucht,
zehn stunden die woche auf geringfügige basis eine publikation assistenz für ein sachbuch,
also das klingt ja auch nach einer netten aufgabe da mal irgendwie ein buch zu publizieren heraus zu geben und da irgendwie daran beteiligt zu sein mit einer flexiblen arbeitszeit könnte man also als nebenjob oder kleinen,
ehrenamtlichen job fast sehen damit sind schon die woche schon nebenjob ehrenamtlich suchen sie außerdem noch grafikerin und web designerinnen da gibt's also auch nochmal,
viel zu tun in wien wo ihr gerade euch orientieren könnte.
Tschüss.
So dann kommen wir zu den zu den nachrichten der woche,
ich weiß gar nicht ob das jetzt so gut sortiert sind wir gehen sie mal durch also erstmal im märz zwanzig achtzehn hat facebook ja,
angefangen mit einer untersuchung nachdem,
cambridge analytica skandal,
diskutiert wurde und haben gesagt ok wir müssen jetzt mal gucken was wir hier was es noch so für apps gibt versuchen wir doch mal herauszufinden was die apps die wir da irgendwie in unserem facebook zulassen,
tun.
Und jetzt haben sie festgestellt dass sie insgesamt in dem zuge dieser untersuchung,
neunundsechzig tausend apps suspendiert haben die,
größte der größere teil dieser neuen sechzigtausend apps wurde dann beendet wenn sie das weil sie nicht mit der facebook kooperation mit der facebook- untersuchung kooperiert haben also die entwickler haben sich nie,
gemeldet zehntausend wurden.
Gefleckt als potenziell persönliche daten einer nicht akzeptabel nutzung unterziehen und.
Und ja das hatte ich auch jetzt sehr interessant und jetzt sagen sie dass sie,
um mit ungefähr vierhundert entwicklern probleme haben,
das verstehe ich irgendwie,
also sagen sie ja mit vierhundert entwicklern probleme und im august zwanzig achtzehn haben sie noch von vierhundert apps gesprochen also august zwanzig achtzehn war der zwischenstand vierhundert apps jetzt sind wir bei neunundsechzig.
Na die haben wahrscheinlich dieselbe app oder tausend abend drin und äh.
Das kann vielleicht auch sein,
genau sie sagen also vier diese zehntausende apps gehen auf vierhundert entwickler zurück,
die im zweifelsfall für mehrere kundinnen und kunden die gleich ähnliche apps gebaut haben testversion gebaut haben und so weiter die also teilweise auch nicht die playit fahren,
aber es gibt auf jeden fall irgendwie vierhundert,
entwickler accounts bei facebook die insgesamt bis mehrere zehntausend apps daraus geballert haben die alle irgendwie persönlichen daten extrahieren
oder komischer verdächtiger nutzung,
zu führen mit anderen worten dieses cambridge analytica,
war alles andere als ein einzelfall und.
Ich ja damals schon sagte der eigentliche skandal an cambridge analytica ist dass sie gegen die agb's von facebook verstoßen haben,
wir hätten nämlich für diese daten zahlen müssen denn bei all dem dürfen wir nicht vergessen das business modell von facebook ist mit diesen daten selber geld zu verdienen und die nutzung dieser daten für kunden weil,
kostenpflichtig zu machen und apps die diese daten auf anderen wege extrahieren verstoßen,
das geschäftsmodell von facebook und deswegen muss facebook da jetzt hinterher sein.
Also bei weitem kein einzelfall wie zu erwarten war.
Einfach sind einfach sind schon einzelfälle nur halt sehr viele.
Genau in,
in den usa hatten wir jetzt auch einen bedauerliche einzelfall von einer million einzelfällen und da waren,
datensätze von von medizinischen daten.
Im im internet frei zugänglich der es ging da um ein picture communications system also ein medizin in eine,
app ein system das also arztpraxen benutzen,
rücken aufnahmen und patienten
auf solchen servern zu speichern spezifisch hier rücken aufnahmen und computer tomographie aufnahmen
hochauflösend bilder in der regel mit zahlreichen informationen gespickt die person die informationen sind alle personen bezogen sowas wie geburtsdatum von nachname termine untersuchung behandelnden arzt und solche dinge was halt üblicherweise auch zum röntgenbild,
oder einem cd oder draufsteht.
In deutschland sind von dieser eine million einzelfälle entfallen dreizehntausend einzelfälle auf deutschland fünf standorte,
mehr als die hälfte dieser dreizehntausend einzelfälle sind mit bildern größere teil sind patientin aus dem raum ingolstadt,
und dem raum campen ja.
Schöne viele die kommen dateien wahrscheinlich.
Die daten waren also alle einfach nur auf dem einfach ohne irgendwelche zugangs beschränkung auf einem server.
So der fdp server im netz oder klassiker.
Ich hab den artikel gelesen da stand auch genau drin über welche art von servern welches protokoll dazu gerissen wurde da bin ich mir jetzt nicht mehr hundertprozentig firmen aber einfach.
Sag halt offen rum.
Offen fertig ist eigentlich dann auch egal ob du fdp oder oder was auch immer sprichst wenn du vorher keine automatisierung machst dann ist es,
egal deswegen finde ich es kann ich's nur begrüßen wenn wir quasi am gleichen tag in deutschland die entscheidung treffen,
oder einen tag später die entscheidung treffen den krankenschein zu digitalisieren ja es soll das jetzt irgendwie nicht mehr sollte kein gelben schein mehr bekommen sondern es soll irgendwie digital stattfinden,
das kann ja nur gut gehen,
und da sind wir natürlich sehr sehr gespannt sollen also der krankenschein,
digital übermittelt werden ausgedacht hat sich das peter altmaier.
Auch die rezepte.
Hat sich natürlich auch eine sehr kluge klugen zeitpunkt ausgesucht um um so etwas zu veröffentlichen damit da werden wir noch viel spaß haben.
Da werden wir noch viel spaß haben auch wenn ich ja grundsätzlich sagen muss sehr gesundheitsbereich der gehört auch.
Digitalisiert also es ist schon etwas was riesen chancen bietet aber man muss natürlich hier mit erfahrung,
an die sache rangeht und manchmal frage ich mich ob einfach diese erfahrung kollektiv in diesem land schon ausreichend besteht andererseits muss man ja auch erstmal gegen die wand laufen manchmal ums überhaupt zu merken dementsprechend.
Derartige software ideen in deutschland diese ganzen großprojekte die werden alle vor die wand gefahren weil sie zu zu zu zu schrott,
diskutiert werden ja also besonderes elektronisches anwalt postfach die mail ja,
das geht alles in deutschland einen weg nämlich den das zwei zwanzig jahre darüber irgendwelche schönen sachen diskutiert werden und ganz viele kompromisse gemacht werden müssen
und dann gilt eben wie schon so oft sagte kompromiss kompromiss kompromiss kompromiss und dann steht das ding brach dort.
Na gut was dir was die alternative sonst uns hast du diesen konsens nicht mal auf der anderen seite wünschen wir uns ja immer mit sprache rechte und redet doch mal mit denen man mit denen dann versuchen sie halt einfach da ein kompromiss zu machen
um überhaupt irgendwas.
Sicherheit gibt's keine kompromisse.
Was soll ja nicht ja ist ja auch 'ne frage system design was soll's überhaupt können et cetera sie sicherheits erinneren im im design auch mit drin welche daten werden überhaupt wo erhoben et cetera und.
Du ich darf daran erinnern dass der martin so ungefähr jede martin schiller sich so gut für jede digitale patienten akten app dies da draußen gibt in einem zeitraum von zwei monaten in der mittagspause auseinander genommen hat.
Aber es gibt die gute nachricht es es gibt eine gute nachricht.
Haben wir eigentlich single für gute nachrichten.
Neben keine zimmer jemand machen die gute nachricht es gibt die gute nachricht.
In dänemark wurden zweiunddreißig viel urteile aufgehoben die menschen in den knast geschickt haben,
aufgrund von,
ergebnissen der vorratsdatenspeicherung also zweiunddreißig menschen,
sind jetzt aus dem knast gelassen worden weil sie zu unrecht verurteilt waren,
aufgrund von vorratsdatenspeicherung daten und zwar,
findet in dänemark gerade eine review von zehntausend siebenhundert kriminalfilm fällen statt die sie neu aufrollen müssen weil sie festgestellt haben
dass die geo locations daten die sie aus ihrer vorratsdatenspeicherung holen nicht,
korrekt sind gibt's nämlich bestimmte gletschers in der software die diese daten die rohdaten die von den zelt tower,
locations kommen fehlerhaft in gps daten über,
und das hat eben zur folge dass bestimmte daten ausgelassen wurden.
In der konversion also in der übertragung von und sonstigen,
locations daten das heißt nur teile der daten wurden in das endgültige daten set aufgenommen,
und die lokation staaten die aus dem aus dieser vhs herausfallen sind unvollständig.
Das ist jetzt erstmal schön für die zweiunddreißig menschen die unschuldig verurteilt waren,
den sie auch noch finden müssen nämlich freispruch frei sprüche oder ausschüsse von verdächtigen personen aufgrund fehlerhafte daten wir haben jetzt nur den eintritt in den einen fehler,
ja jetzt ist er der anderen fehler findet ihr wisst also jetzt mal mindestens zweiunddreißig,
heute wieder einknüpfen für die ist das 'ne schlechte nachricht,
und mal schauen was es da sonst noch für für viel urteile oder eingestellte.
Verfahren gab weil sie weil sie irgendwie verdächtige aus dem aus dem fokus genommen haben weil sie aufgrund ihrer tollen vorratsdatenspeicherung,
nicht quasi nicht mehr verdächtig waren oder ein alibi hatten oder sonstiges geil habt ihr gut gemacht.
Wobei selbst hier sich einfach um schlecht erhoben indizien oder beweise handelt und nicht,
sie eine eigenschaft von vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Eine eigenschaft der software die dafür genutzt wurde,
was gleichermaßen also ist ein implementierung problem ja die haben ja gesagt okay wir nehmen die lokation zeiten haben sich irgendwie software dafür schreiben lassen wo die software hat einen fehler,
das ist halt mal echt wenn dein back.
Der kann ja viel kein viel kaputt aber wenn er für zweiunddreißig leute im knast gehen,
schuldig dann hast du echt 'n scheiß back.
Ja also da wird man irgendwie auch äh der haut dieser premiere möchte man nicht.
Klingt immer so ne zweiunddreißig leute im knast na ja sind ja wieder freigelassen worden zu dem zeitpunkt kann ihr leben bereits komplett zerstört sein und das auch und wieder dringlich es ist jetzt kein spaß ja dementsprechend.
Haben wir noch eine gute nachricht.
Genau und diesmal bezieht sich auch ganz explizit auf die vorratsdatenspeicherung als solche denn,
jetzt ist es so das bundesverwaltungsgericht hat entschieden dass die vorratsdatenspeicherung in deutschland die er derzeit ausgesetzt ist auch weiterhin vorerst ausgesetzt bleibt.
Denn es hat beschlossen zwei klagen die hier vorgebracht wurden gegen die vorratsdatenspeicherung an den,
weiterzuleiten kennt ja diesen mechanismus der eugh reiß dinge nicht an sich sondern es wird eben von,
gerichten in den mitgliedsländern der europäischen union
an den eugh zur erklärung im kontext der europäischen auf europäischer ebene geltenden gesetze und regelungen und der verfassung,
jetzt hab ich mein satz verschult also die nationalen,
richte leiten das an den eugh weiter damit er das prüfen kann.
Geschieht jetzt hier dementsprechend,
die vorratsdatenspeicherung ausgesetzt,
um mal das vielleicht ein bisschen zu kontext realisieren wir haben einen schönen bericht dazu bei politik und ich habe mir mal kurz diese kleine timeline der auch in einem absatz drin war nochmal rausgeschrieben und das einfach auch nochmal sacken zu lassen zweitausendsieben
haben wir in deutschland das erste freust datenspeicherung gesetz erhalten das wurde dann zwanzig zehn vom bundesverfassungsgericht gekippt geht so nicht.
Zwanzig vierzehn kippt dann der eugh auch noch die dem zugrunde liegende eu-richtlinie,
woraufhin ein jahr später die groko meint org geil dann machen wir doch gleich mal ein neues vorratsdatenspeicherung gesetz warum auch immer,
das dann wieder unter feuer gerät,
einerseits weil dagegen geklagt wird,
äh andererseits weil auch das eugh diverse vorratsdatenspeicherung gesetze in diversen europäischen mitgliedsländern,
da bin ich jetzt gerade nicht ganz so sicher ob sie auch das in deutschland montiert haben auf jeden fall,
haben sie da einen rundum schlag gemacht,
rund zwanzig siebzehn ist halt auch die erste klage nämlich von space nett dann auch entsprechend gewonnen worden woraufhin die bundesnetzagentur die speicher pflicht für diese zweite vw-gesetz,
ausgesetzt hat derzeit klagt auch noch die telekom gegen die speicher pflicht an sich,
das wird gerade verhandelt mit anderen worten da ist so schnell nicht damit zu rechnen dass hier viel bewegung in die sache reinkommt,
kann er noch,
wird sein dass der eugh nochmal über diese vw klagen befindet und vorerst also keine vorstellung.
Ey komm wir doch erst mal nicht im knast.
Nicht so schnell zumindest.
Weißt du auch nicht im knast gekommen ist.
Also die leute die renate künast im internet beleidigen denn damit die,
drecks fotzen richter ein geistes krankes urteil gegen die renate künast gefällt das justiz ja wie eine schlampe aussehen lässt die auf den sondern müll gehört so schreibt es der postillon und,
das ist wirklich echt irre die hat also sie wurde,
als stück scheiße beschimpft als tricks fotze und hat dann dagegen,
hat diese urheber dieser beleidigungen,
angezeigt und das irgendwie dann vor gericht gebracht und als ein berliner gericht hat eben gesagt ja das werden also schon zulässige meinungsäußerung und auseinandersetzungen in der sache ja,
schon echt,
geil sie wollte die persönlichen daten der kommentatoren bekommen von facebook um dann rechtlich gegen diese person vorzugehen also sie brauchte quasi ein urteil indem.
Die straftat anerkannt wird als straftat damit facebook zur verfolgung dieser straftat die daten dieser person rausgeben muss ne das war also das was da verhandelt wurde.
Und ja das gericht hat halt gesagt das wäre also nicht zu.
Das wäre jetzt einfach nicht der fall das werden also zulässige meinungsäußerung sie sie werden zwar teilweise sehr polemisch und überspitzt und zudem sexistisch ja,
aber das haben wir das mit ihrem verhalten selbst provoziert ja was was hat die renate künast auch so einen kurzen rock an ja unglaublich ne.
Das kann also von einer schmiere kann ja nicht ausgegangen werden wenn die äußerungen im kontext einer sache auseinandersetzung steht ich echt geil und deswegen hat sie hier dieses dieses verfahren.
Verloren.
Ja also der postillon mutmaßlich auch noch über die gründe also wie es zu urteil kommen kann und
schließt einfach hier offenbar wurden die richter als kinder ein wenig zu viel gefickt denn sie entschieden dass sich bei den beleidigungen auseinandersetzungen in der sache handelt wie genau die holen nüsse zu diesem urteil kam ist derzeit noch unklar.
Also unglaublich.
Ich liebe den postillon er bringt echt auf.
So wird das nix hier mit der verfolgung von.
Also es geht irgendwie es ging in der auseinandersetzung darum dass renate künast neunzehnhundertsechsundachtzig in berliner abgeordnetenhaus gab es eine diskussion,
wo
sie irgendwie in den zusammenhang gesagt hat zum thema sex mit kindern gesagt hat wenn keine gewalt im spiel ist und das haben die dann quasi die richter gesagt als naja das ist ja dann auch sehr
provokativ und ist ja im sexuellen bereich also wenn man über den sechser im bereich redet dann ist es ja auch eine sache auseinandersetzung
als dreckspatz oder schlampe bezeichnet zu werden ja das ist schon wirklich sehr.
Interessant was erlaube netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz ja das finde ich schon sehr interessant,
also ich kann mir schwer vorstellen dass das dass das bestand haben wird und.
Teil würde ich erwarten würde ich einfach.
Na wer mir andere gesetze sind besser gemacht.
Ja ne die gesetze sind sehr gut gemacht was wir wissen ist also die eu über urheberrecht richtlinie die ja jetzt verabschiedet wurde und deswegen weil sie eine richtlinie ist jetzt in nationales gesetz über,
führt werden muss und zwar bis zum ende der umsetzung frist am siebten juni zwanzig einundzwanzig ja müssen wir also diese eu urheberrechte richtlinie umsetzen in ein deutsches gesetz und da hat dann die fdp-fraktion
mal gefragt achso ja hier übrigens ne wie wollt ihr eigentlich die urheber rechts richtlinie ohne uploadfilter umsetzen weil das hat uns der axel voss ja so versprochen
na der hat der axel voss hat ja immer gesagt geht niemand will load filter niemand hat die ablaut filter zu errichten das geht ganz einfach ohne uploadfilter und dann hat die fdp gefragt na ja gut der axel voss war ja schon jetzt aus verschiedenen
gründen nicht in der lage das zu zu,
sattes funktionsfähig zu verargumentieren ja oder seine aussage irgendwie mit mit überlegungen zu unter füttern haben sie gesagt da fragen wir doch einfach mal.
Die bundesregierung und da kam dann,
die die antwort also die frage welchen vorschlag die bundesregierung im deutschen bundestag zu artikel zur umsetzung des artikels siebzehn also der ehemalige artikel dreizehn unterbreiten wird ist noch nicht entschieden wäre aber ganz klar
das etwaige,
etwaige bestehende umsetzung spielräume geprüft werden sollen um einerseits urheberrecht im internet zu schützen und andererseits die meinungs- und informationsfreiheit zu waren es wäre auch weiterhin das erklärte ziel
diese geplanten maßnahmen ohne einen einsatz von upload filtern umzusetzen aber wie das geht nicht.
Ja wer hätte damit rechnen können ne der hat ja keiner mit rechnen können also vielleicht sollten sie nochmal axel voss fragen der weiß dass ja wie das geht.
Tja.
Expertin dann kann man ein buch empfehlen hab ich bekommen auch habe ich geschenkt bekommen geschossen gekrochen.
Komm hast du schon gelesen.
Permanent ne also ich bin dabei ist zu lesen ich will aber noch nicht fertig ist zu lesen.
Und das liegt daran dass ich in den letzten tagen und wochen relativ viel unterwegs waren,
und ja auch wie man vielleicht hört ein bisschen krank bin und deswegen versuche meine schlaf zeiten zu optimieren.
Deswegen war es gestern auch fünf stunden nochmal im anderen podcast zu gast.
Ja genau.
Wenn ich dafür aber das also buche ist empfohlen link ist in den shots natürlich mit affiliate link damit wir schön tragen können was ihr kauft und geld dafür bekommen,
euch in den den daten kranken zuzuführen.
Und was noch alles so kauft wenn ihr das.
Das wollen wir auch geld dran verdienen und so ne also bevor wir wissen ja.
Das wollen wir wissen vor allem ja leute dieses notizbuch kaufen kaufen auch sechs puppe aloe.
Hallo hut sekundenkleber und löw,
um die mikrofone aus ihren telefon raus zu holen wie etwa neun jahre empfiehlt.
Ich bin der äh hat auf jeden fall mit seinem buch die ungefähr wirklich erstaunliche klage eingetreten die zum buch kriegen könnte denn,
es klagt jetzt die us-regierung darauf dass er quasi die,
vertraulichkeit vereinbarung die er verletzt mit diesem buch ja er hat ja vertraulichkeit vereinbarung gehabt mit und und dadurch dass er dieses buch schreibt hätte er.
Gemäß dieser vertraulichkeit vereinbarung dieses bevor es veröffentlicht zur überprüfung und geben müssen.
Ja dass sie sagen können ja das nicht das nicht lieber schwarzen stift kurz so weil er es nicht gemacht hat sagen sie das ist jetzt quasi ihr wissen,
was da veröffentlicht wird und deswegen klagen sie jetzt sagen also diese geheimnisse information sollen unsere nation schützen nicht den persönlichen profit dienen,
und deswegen möchten sie diese dieses geld haben,
um sicherzustellen dass norden keine einnahmen durch diesen vertrauensbruch generiert sagen quasi du verstößt damit gegen unser.
Das tust du zu deiner.
Und aus diesem grunde möchten wir diese einnahmen haben damit du damit du nicht auch noch finanziellen vorteil aus deinem vertrauensbruch ziehen kannst.
Ich bin ja kein anwalt ich habe gestern im sender garten auch erzählt warum.
Ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen dass sie damit durchkommen.
Ich kann mir in den usa derzeit alles vorstellen also von daher aber ich meine es schon hart nämlich nicht nur dass sie nicht mit urheberrecht argumentiert haben das wäre so die deutsche variante.
Ich glaube dass wir werden sie wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie tun aber er ist auf jeden fall eine.
Durchaus interessante geschichte gibt dem buch natürlich aufwind und ich bin mir
andererseits auch im unklaren darüber wie die jetzt ernsthaft dieses geld einzutreiben könnten ich könnte mir vorstellen dass sie das wenn es da ein urteil gibt allenfalls.
Über die für die für den erlös in den usa wo natürlich der größere teil des erlöses.
Du schickst alle zu amazon jetzt in deinem leben die ganze kohle gleich.
Ja sicher alles an die eu alles an die usa.
Am ende wollen sie dann auch noch die affiliate kohle haben.
Die verklagen uns dann auch noch.
Ja auf jeden fall ein ein schöner eine schöne werbung nochmal für dieses buch.
Markus becker hat schon gelesen hatte eine eine,
rezension dazu geschrieben ja.
Ich bin mal gespannt ich werde es noch zu ende lesen heute.
So was auch sehr gut ist dass die bundesregierung jetzt die weichen für die trockene ökonomie gestellt hat.
Darauf habe ich.
Das habe ich mir ich habe die ganze zeit also wie ihr wisst wir fordern ja seit längerem von der bundesregierung dass sie die weichen für die trockene ökonomie stellt.
Stellt sich nur die frage was zur hölle ist eine token ökonomie.
Das ist wirklich eine frage,
ja das ganze ist nämlich eine strategie ja hier wenn ich nur die weichen gestellt hier werden strategien in die welt gelassen ganz konkret geht es um die papa blockchain strategie der bundesregierung,
wo man sich halt auch fragt was erlaube bundesministerium für wirtschaft und energie und bundesministerium der finanzen dieses ausgehängt haben.
Ich muss ganz ehrlich sein ich bin bei dem ding nur bis zur seite viel gekommen.
Im inhaltsverzeichnis weißt du was auf seite vier steht.
Da war die bingo karte voll oder.
Wir wollen deutschlands führende position ausbauen.
Mach mal mach mal mach mal.
Diese filter betrug jetzt demnächst nur mit der blockchain ja also hast du das.
Na ja wird halt einfach jetzt kohle in die finanzindustrie rein gegossen damit sie da irgendwie die kohle in irgendwelchen projekten verbreiten können.
Aber sie haben jetzt davon gehört dass facebook das macht dann müssen muss ja irgendwie auch was getan werden auf nationaler ebene,
warum ausgerechnet die finanzen industrie förderung braucht.
Schließt sich mir nur eingeschränkt.
Haben sie das letzte mal erst vor zehn jahren schon wieder.
Ja hatten die da nicht ja gesagt da war doch irgendwie was war nicht irgendwie haben wir euch nicht den arsch.
Ich finde das äußerst interessant also diese ganze diese blockchain hype frei es ist ja so,
die blockchain.
Für ein relativ spezifisches problem.
Und der immer wenn jemand eine lösung für dein problem findet dann rennen alle los und wollen auch das problem haben,
ja und weil es dafür jetzt eine schöne lösung gibt wollen sie dann auch ein irgendwann zu lösen mit der blockchain ja wie ich glaube das war,
äh ich glaube mit green der lautete wenn die frage lautet könnte nicht die blockchain dann antwortet da lautet die antwort nein und,
die das das schöne ist dass diese ganzen leute die nicht versteht hier erkennen oh die blockchain ist eine lösung für ein schönes problem das problem wollen wir jetzt auch haben die verstehen nicht dass sie genau dieses problem sind
was mit einer blockchain gelöst werden soll ja wenn ich jetzt hier lese,
blockchain im finanzsektor der finanzsektor ist das problem,
mit bitcoin gelöst werden sollte ja also es ist echt so irgendwie oh es gibt eine lösung gegen uns dann müssen wir sie uns zeigen machen das geht ja weiter mit.
Staatliche blockchain infrastruktur,
die ganze idee davon ist dass du keine kein staat hass keine zentralen instanzen keine also
keine einzelne mächtige institution ja und genau die identität digitale identitäten vertrauens dienste staatliche blockchain infrastruktur
projekte der verwaltung weißt du das letzte was die deutsche verwaltung jetzt noch brauchen ist eine blockchain als hätten sie nicht schon genug probleme.
Also das ist ich finde das ist äußerst äußerst unterhaltsam sich das anzuschauen oder hier punkt drei,
weil wie wir alle wissen gibt's ja viel zu wenig investitionen in blockchain gerade ne milliarden liegen in diesen scheiß dingern,
jeder jede jedes initial coin of streicht irgendeine millionen ein macht danach irgendwie ein gitter bekommst du geht mit der kohle weg weil wir alle wissen dass sie lieber geld haben als irgendwelche krypton,
wir wissen
das größte problem was wir gerade haben ist wie zögerlich in blockchain investiert wird ne das ist ja wirklich ganz schwierig mit der blockchain gerade mal irgendwie.
Investitionen klarzumachen ne wenn die wenn du irgendwie nur blockchain sagst denn rennt ihr die die,
die venture kapitalisten hinterher und halte dich fest und wenn du versuchst auf dem blau bauen zu klettern klettern die hinterher ja da müssen wir natürlich echt investitionen ermöglichen geil es ist wirklich um mann ey das ist das ich finde das so peinlich,
das ist peinlich ich wette mit dir ich gehe jetzt hier ich ich soll jetzt auf irgendeine seite und nehmen irgendein satz und ich wette der ist witzig,
die bis die bundesregierung stellt staatliche identifizierung bereit
und entwickelt dieses ständig weiter sowohl im sinne der nutzer freundlichkeit und zur gewährleistung des hohen sicherheitsniveau zum beispiel die funktion des neuen personalausweis ist ja okay der satz ist,
bis auf nutzer freundlichkeit ständige weiterentwicklung richtig,
sie prüft daneben in verschiedenen verwaltungs- verfahren ob und wie weit,
abgeleitete digitale identität der privatwirtschaft für verwaltung verfahren beziehungsweise bestimmte rechts geschäfts anerkannt werden können da ist der witz hauptsächlich dass sie,
den dass sie noch ein typo in ihrer strategie haben.
Also vor allem es wird hier viel rum geschoben aber nirgendwo wird mal klar erklärt,
warum jetzt eigentlich ausgerechnet die technologie blockchain bei diesem ganzen scheiß helfen soll also wo ihr wird überhaupt
hier wird überhaupt gar kein problem formuliert was auch nur ansatzweise darauf hinweisen könnte dass eine blockchain dabei hilft sondern es ist sozusagen die blockchain wird sozusagen heilsbringer,
das ist das was mich so primär daran stört sondern ein heilsbringer mit mit blockchain wird alles gut ne als ob man das nicht vorher auch machen kann und diese schöne frage mit brauchen wir eine blockchain nein ja das ist ja auch so die aller letzten endes ist eine blockchain.
Jetzt ja auch nicht mal zu kryptisch zu reden es ist eine datenbank esse datenbank,
und da stehen daten drin und datenbanken gibt's auch schon seit dreißig vierzig jahren dass sich nichts neues jeder von uns hat irgendwie welche auf seinem rechner es gibt,
ohne ende datenbanken,
in verschiedenen ausrichtung und optimierung und manche sind optimiert für schnell für gleichzeitig für viel oder eine kombination daraus gibt für alles mögliche datenbank eine blockchain ist eine datenbank,
die explizit für.
Keinen zentralen vertrauens ort gebaut ist das ist das kernproblem was hier gelöst werden soll und das mit einschränkungen auch gelungen nur dieses problem haben halt nicht viele,
das haben halt eigentlich nur ja bitcoins also kryptowährungen die versuchen ohne eine banken infrastruktur in irgendeiner form ihren wert zu halten und du trotzdem,
eben dem zustand dieser datenbank vertrauen kannst das ist eigentlich alles mehr ist es nicht,
und daraus kann man nicht eine komplette strategie für den staat machen für was was das problem was was was was wollt ihr lösen,
eure verwaltung besser werden durch eine blockchain das kann einem keiner erklärt ist wirklich,
hahne büchern.
Wenn du eine zentrale institution bist wie eine bank oder eine regierung dann lautet next level,
blockchain lautet datenbank mach eine datenbank du bist eine zentrale institution deswegen machst du eine datenbank und nicht eine blockchain aber zum glück ich war der sätze tim die bundesregierung pilotiert,
blockchain basierte digitale identitäten sie wird prüfen ob diese blockchain basierten digitalen identitäten,
einen klaren mehrwert gegenüber bestehenden lösungen versprechen und ob sie,
so gestaltet werden können,
dass die datenschutzrechtlichen vorgaben gerecht werden hierbei werden auch geeignete weitere anwendungen evaluiert grundsätzlich wird für die umsetzung und weiterentwicklung digitaler identitäten das prinzip der identität sicherheit und der technologie neutralität vertreten.
Ich fass zusammen wir prüfen wir gucken mal wie evaluieren mal wir schauen mal wir machen mal im labor das ist.
Das ist keine strategie.
Das ist keine strategie und es ist vor allem auch am ende kann ich dir auch sagen was bei diesen ganzen prüfungen rauskommt,
ja geht nicht zu teuer oder billigere lösung und einfache lösungen die schon seit zwanzig jahren existieren brauchen wir alles nicht,
ich will ja überhaupt nicht behaupten dass nicht eine blockchain,
irgendwo auch im finanzsektor durchaus sinnvolle geschichte sein kann um ein bestimmtes teil problem zu lösen,
wir hatten ja hier diese diskussion über facebook libra auch da kommt eine blockchain zum einsatz in einem kleinen rahmen um die,
teilnehmer eines kleinen marktes nämlich der unternehmen die sich dieses libra konstruktions angeschlossen haben,
sozusagen das vertrauen unter denen herzustellen weil sie da halt auch das problem hast was halt keine zentrale instanz an,
da sitzen halt zwanzig teilnehmer herum wollen irgendwie geld austauschen wollen sich sicher sein dass das es immer stimmt da macht eine blockchain sind ne weil 's ein kleiner kreis ist von leuten die sich eigentlich nicht vertrauen.
Aber dafür brauchen wir auch keine blockchain strategie der bundesregierung aber nicht,
es ist einfach dann dann probiert man das und dann hat man das und dann läuft das nun geht das man es jetzt auch alles zehn jahre her ist jetzt irgendwie.
Das schöne ist eigentlich ich kann auch genau vorstellen wie sowas passiert ist da ist wahrscheinlich in irgendeiner in irgendeiner,
pressekonferenz in irgend einer kleinen anfrage hat mal irgendjemand gesagt liebe bundesregierung,
habt ihr eigentlich in eine strategie des umgang ist damit und dann haben sie gesagt funny,
haben wir nicht wir brauchen eine blockchain strategie was ist denn los ich meine klar braucht jeder wie er war eine blockchain strategie ich habe auch eine blockchain strategie weiträumig meiden so aber die jeder braucht ne jeder braucht 'ne blockchain strategie.
Ja wir brauchen wir eigentlich eine blockchain strategie diesmal nicht mehr darüber reden.
Ja klar ne ne unsere blockchain strategie ist ganz einfach hotel.
Buddeln war das ja nochmal wollen doch aber ich hab 's nicht parat.
Oh jetzt muss ich ein witz erklären kennst du nicht rote ding mein holding also dass die dass die bitcoins behältst und nicht verkaufst,
weil du natürlich für die long game drin bist dann gibt es irgendein typen der irgendwann mal geschrieben hat einmal ein holding.
Okay.
Deswegen ist unsere strategie ja wir geben dir einfach nicht aus weil die werden ja immer mehr wert unsere bitcoins holding jetzt hatte ich dann auch tausend.
Die sich anbieten in maps ne hoden also du musst deine du musst auf jeden fall deine bitcoins wurde alles andere ist.
Du hast ich vermute halt einfach du hast ein hotel die schon längst gemacht.
Ja jetzt ist er hier noch mit in die show notes nehmen das hotel diplom.
Ja so ist das was wurde es war.
Oder hab ich das ist das das ist doch immer über.
Du das ist gar nicht so schlecht ein hotel diplom da hat man was hat man was eigenes da steht man dann auch.
Ist der beste strategie schreibt sogar fonds also aber vorsicht auch wirklich,
vor bitcoin holding ist west,
ja okay da da ist ein holding erklärt.
Macht am meisten kaviar.
Geht's ja wikipedia.
Natürlich gibt's den.
Für den klaren testen sie helmut högl.
Holding holding holding ist unsere blockchain strategie.
Okay lass uns äh weitermachen.
Jetzt kommen wir zu den terminen.
Track 3
Ja termine termine termine haben wir wieder mal und zwar am achtzehnten bis zum zwanzigsten,
toba gibt es leckereien in hannover das heck
over zwanzig neunzehn des hannover steht an und da wird fleißig gehackt wie der name schon nahe liegt,
über das wochenende das ganze findet statt in der bürger schule im stadtteilzentrum nordstadt hannover,
tickets call vor papas und weitere informationen findet ihr unter ova punkt de.
Und davor tatsächlich am elften oktober zwanzig neunzehn.
Und am zwölften oktober zwanzig neunzehn und am dreizehnten.
Die drei tage wahnsinn.
Wird das chaos dorf also der chaos computer club düsseldorf achtzehn jahre alt,
achtzehn jahre chaos dorf und diese volljährigkeit wird natürlich gebührend gefeiert,
in der hütten straße fünfundzwanzig in düsseldorf ja da gibt's irgendwie,
eine seite die verlinkt haben und da geht da ist man natürlich wenn man dort ist.
Verstehe gut das bringt uns ans ende der sendung was noch ein paar danksagungen.
Genau ich würde gerne danken nora christian jan felix robin björn und lukas.
Aber hier mitgemacht ist ja ganz schön lange her dass wir das letzte mal hier so eine studio sendung gemacht haben ne.
Ja war ja und jetzt auch schon wieder ein world congress das zeichnet sich ab am horizont.
Ja zeichnet sich ab ja gut aber da machen wir keine bühnenshow.
Nee da hast du keine zeit für.
Und ich danke auch.
Es steht leider zu erwarten.
Kein kein kein nervt nee wir haben jetzt gemacht mama aber bestimmt bald auch mal wieder am,
schonmal darüber nachgedacht wird das noch ein bisschen,
besser organisiert bekommen aber jetzt versorgen wir euch erst mal wieder mit updates viele termine eingetragen die wir gedenken halbwegs zu halten.
Ja wir haben termine durchgeplant jetzt also wir wir sind wir wollen jetzt uns wieder dem einwöchigen rhythmus opfern.
Der eine sortieren so und damit wir das auch gut halten können wir jetzt erstmal schluss damit die sendung auch rauskommt würde vielen dank fürs zuhören ja sprechen hören uns dann.
Track 3